I have a story for you today that is
both childish and very disturbing which
is actually a surprisingly common
combination in the current era it's
being reported that the president is
increasingly using his personal mobile
phone to call people without chief of
staff John Kelly knowing about it and
arguably it's also to get around White
House records of the calls that take
place and the sort of immediate obvious
question is who is Trump calling that he
doesn't want John Kelly to know about
and what is it that they're talking
about during these phone calls and we
know because multiple sources inside the
White House have revealed it that when
Trump uses the White House switchboard
system to make calls it generates a log
it generates a list of calls that goes
to the chief of staff formerly it was
Reince Priebus now it's John Kelly when
Trump uses his personal cell phone it is
much more difficult for John Kelly to
know what's going on unless someone
tells him hey by the way Trump called XY
or Z and this is very very telling
especially when you consider why it was
that John Kelly was brought in and some
of the changes that happened right after
John Kelly was brought in he came in
replacing Reince Priebus and was sort of
seen as the guy who was gonna get the
riffraff out of the Oval Office
very quickly Sean Spicer left Anthony
scaramouche II was out Steve Bannon was
gone and as sources in the White House
say Trump is trying to get Kelly out of
the way as a gatekeeper by using his
mobile phone and to continue talking to
some of these people there are unrelated
reports that say Cory Lewandowski is in
touch directly with Trump on his mobile
phone Lewandowski was Trump's former
very very wacky campaign manager and
John Kelly specifically tried to put
some distance between Trump and
Lewandowski obviously because
Lewandowski is an absolutely terrible
influence on Trump so we have kind of
like a political question the concern
politically is who's Trump talking to
what are they talking about
and how is that influencing Trump's
position on policy the legal question is
about the White House Records and about
security concerns the White House
switchboard system is designed
for sensitive topics to be discussed
it's a secure system it is a tracked
system it's logged and it is private is
Trump talking about classified
information on his personal phone
because anyone could be taking advantage
of the security vulnerabilities on
Trump's personal phone and those
conversations would not be logged and
captured just for government
accountability and transparency they
could also be intercepted by foreign
powers or even by American intelligence
and that's sort of where my curiosity is
on this thing right number one could
Trump's personal phone be bugged by a
foreign intelligence service that's the
obvious question but question number two
about Trump's personal cell phone use is
is it possible that one of our own
intelligence services is surveilling
Donald Trump's phone and this is
potentially a major breach of security
protocol and remember this is the guy
who ran on Hillary can't be trusted
because of her emails and her email
server and documents and humi Abedin
it's all sloppy and let's lock her up
and as usual projection is there
anything the guy accused Hillary or
Obama of that he's not doing himself
yeah and as with all things in the Trump
administration it could be a question
too of if this is incompetence or if
it's something nefarious because maybe
he's doing this deliberately it could be
a way to establish a back-channel with
another entity could be the Russians I
don't know I mean it gets a little bit
conspiratorial but Yap at all going
completely full in on completely
unproven conspiracies but who can blame
the guy right because look at what's
been going on for the last 15 months but
no I think that the key question always
applies here which is is Donald Trump
like the incompetent kid hiding from
mommy and using his mobile phone so that
John Kelly doesn't get a printout of who
he talked to or is it actually far more
calculated to do various and you never
know what's happened to John Kelly - I
mean the guy is a Marine Corps general
yeah and then he was the director of the
Department of Homeland Security super
lol from grace now he's just the
caretaker and he might be out soon and
that's actually the next thing that I
want to talk about today's episode is
made possible in part by zipper
ZPE our banks and other financial
institutions are pretty conservative
when it comes to approving loans and the
major problem with this is not that
they're being cautious but that
immigrants and students and other
disadvantaged groups often don't have
the requisite credit or income to be
approved Zippers goal is to use smart
contract technology and their new
cryptocurrency to provide a
revolutionary method of funding
transactions between borrowers and
lenders worldwide which would allow
people with no or little credit to
borrow currency through alternative
forms of verifying creditworthiness on
Zippers blockchain Zippers initial coin
offering for their new cryptocurrency
starts April 16th if you're watching on
YouTube look in the description for a
link to their website and links to
information about their airdrop and
bounty programs this is not financial
advice and everybody should do their own
research